malgré la chaude journée maurice blais
un résidant du ch et celle des de saint
michel de bellechasse apprécié son tour
de vélo taxi dans le village
pourquoi qu'est ce que ça vous apporte
forme ouverte et c'est justement ce
sentiment de liberté que souhaitait
offrir la propriétaire de l'entreprise
de location de vélos électriques vélos
peux tu voyais ces gens là qui habitait
dans le ch et celle des qui fusaient des
petites sorties en fauteuil roulant qui
parfois venait dans le jazz onj ce à
côté de moi puis je me disais ben c'est
comme injuste fauqué quelque chose pour
eux après de longues recherches dany
gagnon trouve finalement un vélo pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à deux passagers seul
hic il est fabriqué au danemark et pour
l'importer il faut débourser dix sept
mille dollars une somme que ne pouvait
se permettre l'entreprise en parlant
avec la députée de bellechasse est ma
commune jumelée avec la fondation rayon
d'espoir puis donc gelé je leur ai écrit
puis m'ont rapidement répondu pour nous
ça entrer directement dans cette mission
d'offrir une activité qui améliorent la
qualité de vie des designers la
fondation a donc acheté le vélo vélopop
assure de son côté les formations des
intervenants à loisir qui peuvent
utiliser le vélo pour offrir une balade
aux résidents ch et celle des melons de
maison pour tous rue
du pré rue tout
mais ça reste confortable ont contraint
et forcé certains résidents sont dans le
cht de l'an village natal donc ils
voient leur quartier ou revoient leurs
maisons leurs voisins les intervenants
nous disent aussi que ça réduit
l'anxiété 5 ch et sylvie de la région de
bellechasse en bénéficient en semaine
alors que les fins de semaine le bolide
sur trois roues est disponible en
location pour tous ça peut être des
grands enfants de 50 ans qui promènent
leurs parents de 80 ans comme ça pète
des enfants de 40 ans qui promènent leur
enfant de 5 ans 6 ans et l'an prochain
l'entrepreneur espère offrir des tours
guidés de la région à vélo
ici vous et des barres sonores
radio-canada saint michel de bellechasse